in the 90s Elizabeth Berkeley was known
for her role as the high achieving
well-intentioned Jesse Spano in the
sitcom Saved by the Bell however when
she left the show to expand her career
into film her big screen debut generated
unexpected controversy in 1995's Show
Girls Berkeley plays an aspiring Vegas
show girl and performs several sex and
nude scenes the big budget film was the
first of its kind to receive an nc7
rating in the United States and faced
harsh condemnation from critics the
transition from Teen sitcom to erotic
drama proved too jarring for audiences
and many attacked Berkeley for trying
too hard to revamp Her Image during an
anniversary screening of the film in Los
Angeles Berkeley reflected on her
experience saying I had the most
extraordinary experience making the film
which is why when the movie came out it
was more painful than anything you can
imagine